bonsoir il est 18h l'heure du journal de
la rédaction pour débuter cette édition
du 7 mai un beau geste de solidarité
c'était ce matin au parc aubert au
chesnay les élèves du collège charles
péguy ont couru pour l'association ela
qui depuis 1992 lutte contre la
leucodystrophie
mets tes baskets et bats la maladie
c'est le nom de cette opération en 20
ans elle a permis de collecter 23
millions d'euros
on écoute l'une des jeunes participantes
et le témoignage également du père de
gwendal atteint par la maladie il était
présent ce matin voici super important
et dernière je l'avais pas fait la
course et j'avais vraiment regretté donc
pour cette année je voulais vraiment la
faire voilà pour moi et pour mes proches
à chaque fois c'est vraiment un bonheur
de venir et d'être présents pour cette
manifestation
le handicap n'est pas une différence et
au delà du handicap s'équipent les
différences qu'on soit tous à se donner
la main et à s'entraider
selon l'association ela entre trois et
six enfants atteints par la
leucodystrophie naissent chaque année en
france cinq semaines pardon en france
europe à présent et le troisième volet
de notre série autour de l'importance de
l'union dans notre quotidien après les
produits manufacturés les études nous
parlons ce soir d'emploi et c'est une
nouvelle fois le centre d'information
europe direct yvelines qui répond aux
questions de quatre nuls à tort
l'europe va intervenir de deux manières
premièrement elle peut vous fournir elle
peut vous aider à trouver une formation
professionnelle à obtenir une expérience
professionnelle donc nous avons
notamment dans le cadre des programmes
de mobilité européenne
avant c'était ce qu'on appelait le
programme leonardo davinci maintenance
erasmus plus formation professionnelle
et donc c'est un programme qui vise là à
donner une formation professionnelle
tout simplement en faisant partir en
stage les jeunes qui ont besoin
effectivement d'une formation
professionnelle après si une personne
souhaite trouver alors là s'il faut que
la personne soit déjà prêtes à
travailler dans un autre pays c'est pas
en france et dans un autre pays de
l'union européenne l'union européenne a
créé un service qui s'appellerait sûr
que c'est une sorte de gros pôle emploi
européen dans lequel on va retrouver
l'ensemble l'ensemble des offres des
différents pôles emploi il servit servi
en plat national
si vous souhaitez
la course est un exemple qui le verdict
si vous souhaitez apprendre à devenir
clown en italie il ya moyen
l'union européenne peut vous faire
partir dans ce cadre là si vous
souhaitez devenir luthier ou apprendre à
fabriquer des instruments de musique
vous pouvez partir dans ce cadre là
alors par exemple pour le programme de
lutte y est ça va de 18 à 30 ans ça se
fait principalement en allemagne au
luxembourg
mais voilà ça dépend des organismes par
exemple on a le pôle le pôle emploi
international qui fait les demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée et qui n'a pas
de restriction d'âge mais pour d'autres
organismes y poste par exemple se
contenter d'une tranche de 18 26 ans 18
18 25 ans ça dépend vraiment des
organismes on n'a pas une harmonisation
des diplômes et on a facilité la
reconnaissance des diplômes donc
notamment vient ce qu'on appelle lé
centre et nick tariq est donc tout
simplement si une personne a besoin de
faire leurs opérations diplôme il
contacte ce centre de ce centre
ressource et là c'est eux qui vont gérer
en la matière et qui vont
s'assurer que soit il est soit le
diplôme n'a pas besoin d'être reconnus
parce qu'il est applicable directement
dans certains cas on a des directives
européennes qui sont intervenus en la
matière ou soit qu'ils vont faire
effectivement une reconnaissance de
diplômes invité du journal à présent et
yannick geoffrey bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau directeur du nhc poker
open 2014 événement sans précédent qui
va se dérouler au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines est dès demain
8 mai et jusqu'au 11 mai tournoi de
poker associatif alors associatif c'est
à dire gratuit sans argent a gagné c'est
votre philosophie c'est exactement ça le
poker pro plaisir poker pur plaisir donc
on joue pourquoi qu'est ce qui motive
alors dans ces cas la compétition il ya
quand même de la compétition j'ai pas
besoin de mettre de l'argent pour avoir
envie de gagner à 2000 joueurs face à
soi et on veut gagner ce combat face à
deux joueurs de 1000 joueurs présents au
vélodrome vélodrome c'est la première
fois que forcément un tel tournoi est
organisé à là-bas on va s'y attarder
mais tout d'abord quelle image avez vous
du poker c'est notre question du jour
j'ai d'argent argent stratégie et puis
je pense qu'il faut est assez malin bien
sûr pour un cachet aussi ses émotions et
être stratège des joueurs autour d'une
table dans des films de western pas très
positif parce que moi je suis une
briseuse donc le jour en bridge je
connais pas bien le poker j'aime les
cartes
mais le poker je pense plus à l'argent
négative trop d'argent est trop de
hasard mélanger probabilité hasard c'est
de la stratégie us aux honnêtes mais il
ya une grosse partie de hasard
l'élection est image parce que je gagne
souvent donc ça va la chance avec le
hasard c'est saint quentinois ont
entendu parler d'argent alors ça tombe
bien si vous n'aimez pas les jeux
d'argent venez voir comment se déroule
ce tournoi en plus l'entrée est libre
totalement gratuit vibre donc on a bien
2000 joueurs qui n'ont pas payé pour
être présent donc ils sont joueurs de
clubs et pour autant ils seront tous
présents on a plus de 2000 joueurs on
allait en guise de ces joueurs sont des
joueurs français alors français on a
également étrangers on a quelques belges
on a les écossais enfin voilà donc on a
essayé de l'ouvrir il se passe super
simple et évidemment mais par contre
effectivement ça vient de partout de
marseille 2,2 toulouse de bordeaux de
dunkerque va ça vient vraiment partout
c'est une grande fête du poker 1 4 jours
seront précisés mais sans précédent il
n'y a pas de tournoi de telle envergure
de nokere associatif non alors le ce
qu'on fait ressemble à ce qui peut être
fait dans le circuit professionnel ça là
pour le coup nous on fait vraiment las
vegas en yvelines c'est à dire que quand
ils vont arriver d'abord l'écrin est
magnifique c'est vélodrome du coup le le
tournoi avec les lumières la musique et
où on se retrouve dans une structure
professionnelle et ça c'est réellement
offert pour ses pour ses joueurs vous
avez voulu faire un show à l'américaine
un peu à saint quentin c'est exactement
ça c'est on se fait plaisir on offre une
structure qui normalement dans le
circuit professionnel
ça coûterait entre 5000 et 10000 euros
le billet d'entrée en circuit
professionnel non l'offre c'était
vraiment le le défi à relever et voilà
comment cela avait réussi à le financer
alors on a un sponsor on a trouvé un
sponsor qui nous a payé la location du
vélodrome et tout le reste du système d
c'est le réseau associatif c'est le
réseau d amis
on va chercher une boîte événementielle
et on est surpris que l accepte
gratuitement nous a amené énormément de
matériel de l'informatique des écrans
pour tous ceux qui vont venir vont être
bluffé pour le coup par les moyens qui
sont déployés à moindre réellement à
moindre coût puisque nous sommes une
petite association on n'avait pas les
moyens de 2
de supporter ce budget là eh bien on a
été malin et on a su aller chercher les
bonnes personnes au bon moment nous
sommes mercredi soir vous êtes en plein
montage
oui sur un montage la g crochet par le
cinquante ans exactement ça là on a 150
bénévoles de mobiliser qui sont en plein
montage et qui seront là sur l'ensemble
du week end
c'est un gros montage on va finir ce
soir à 23h mais demain à 10h 10h30 pour
les joueurs on est prêt 14h pour public
puisqu'il ya un village associatif
village associatif dont on va parler
juste auparavant les chances des joueurs
saint quentinois des joueurs de votre
club ce qu'il faut savoir c'est exclure
les 150 bénévoles c'est essentiellement
des joueurs
en contrepartie du de pouvoir jouer
cette structure il donne une journée de
bénévolat
donc voilà c'est un contrat gagnant
gagnant alors tout le monde est très
très fiers de le faire il ya beaucoup de
joueurs d'ailleurs qui ne joueront pas
qu'ils préféraient être bénévole c'est
une grande aventure y en a qui peuvent
l'emporter
j'espère bien on a plutôt un bon niveau
nous et nash ça fait donc trois ans
maintenant qu'on fait la finale de poker
par équipe à chaque fois on se retrouve
dans le top 10 donc on n'est pas mauvais
donc j'espère bien que qu'on va
décrocher la timbale car ça c'est pour
la partie compétition bien sûr nous y
reviendrons sur cette antenne avec un un
résumé dans nos prochains jours nous la
semaine prochaine mais auparavant il ya
aussi un village associatif on va on va
conclure avec ça d'ailleurs
c'est ouvert au grand public il ya des
animations là encore on est dans le
spectacle et pour tout le monde pas
uniquement les passionnés de poker c'est
exactement ça en fait quand on a eu la
chance de vendre vélodrome on se dire là
c'est génial ce qui nous arrive il faut
le partager
donc on a ouvert une invitation en dix
ans originaire événementiel de 5000 m²
entre vélodrome et la zone bmx ouvrons
le aux associations elles ont toutes
répondu il y aura donc vingt
associations présentes il ya seize
groupes puisque lé concert vendredi soir
et samedi soir
tout ça est totalement offert il ya
initiation tir à l'arc de la magie de la
jongle du trial et puis de la danse et
surtout des concerts voilà ça va être
très festif pour les enfants on ya pensé
il ya des structures gonflables
c'est tout un parc de gonflables pour
enfants voilà donc ça va satisfaire
petits et grands et ça ça va pas
perturber les joueurs
et bien non puisque les joueurs sont à
l'intérieur le village est à l'extérieur
dès qu' il saute du tournoi c'est à dire
dès qu'ils ont
perdu ils vont pouvoir aller profiter de
toutes les animations
et qu'est ce qui fera la différence
alors se retourne pour l'emporter tout à
l'heure il ya aussi une part de hasard
dans le micro trottoir non alors il
existe le hasard au poker y évidemment
mais plus enjoué - odiah de hasard
puisque le hasard c'est des probabilités
ça se maîtrise
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que les
meilleurs joueurs sont toujours en
finale là pour le coup c'est pas c'est
pas du hasard
et puis là il va falloir l'endurance
parce qu'ils vont jouer de 10h à minuit
chaque jour pendant quatre jours oui il
faut de l'endurance il faut être
mentalement prêt physiquement prêt c'est
pas rien donc celui qui va gagner
méritera amplement un voyage à vegas il
ya quand même un beau cadeau offert
c'est un billet pour aller jouer les
championnats du monde de poker à las
vegas rien non c'est très très fier de
pouvoir offrir ça voilà une dernière
question aujourd'hui vous avez le
sentiment que le poker est bien
installée il ya eu un effet de mode il
ya quelques années aujourd'hui poker est
toujours présent et on le voit c'est un
milieu très très vive en 2000
participants il ya énormément de
roulement lors on a des joueurs très
très fidèle depuis plusieurs années nous
ménage ça fait presque neuf ans que
qu'on existe on a 200 adhérents
chaque année il ya eu un peu de turnover
mais non il ya des vrais fidèles
et puis il ya toujours un attrait et
tant qu'on fera de la fête associative
comme ça du poker associatif où il ya
des belles valeurs de partage et on
oublie un petit peu l'enrichissement
financier qui peut y avoir
voilà c'est plutôt sympa et on est
certain de faire le plein d'adhérents
l'année prochaine grâce à ça aussi
merci d'être venu nous parler de ce dont
je suis le montage de ce tournoi qui
débutera dès demain jusqu'au martyre
tout de suite à montigny le bretonneux
au vélodrome merci à vous après le poker
le billard le billard club de
voisins-le-bretonneux qui vient de fêter
ses 20 ans en cadeau le club s'est vu
remettre une nouvelle salle dans le
quartier de la bretonnière inauguré ce
mardi en présence du maire un champion
mondial était présent aussi la démo il a
proposé une démonstration assez
spectaculaire olivier maniscalco et
antonia jld créé en 1993 par quelques
passionnés de la commune dont le premier
adjoint du maire de l'époque
le billard club sinois fête aujourd'hui
ses 20 ans d'existence
à l'époque installé à l'espace de
coville
équipé de seulement quatre billards le
club a bien grandi il inaugurait
d'ailleurs ceci met sa nouvelle salle
dans le quartier de la bretonnière avec
désormais 70 licenciés évitables
flambant neuf le billard se démocratise
à voisins le bretonneux et être un sport
tout public
c'est d'ailleurs une de ses
particularités c'est une des
caractéristiques bigard peuvent être
accessibles à la fois aux jeunes ou la
limite c'est simplement la taille on va
dire
et puis aux anciens puisque c'est un
sport où je jouais très longtemps et ont
même progressé fort sympathique autour
pour l'événement le club recevait la
visite de madame le maire et d'un
champion mondial de billard trois bandes
un champion qui a pu proposer une petite
démonstration très très bien club aussi
mes 20 ans c'est un bon temps jouer avec
les joueurs du club et tout ça c'est
très agréable c'est intéressant au moins
pour eux avec ces nouveaux équipements
le club est maintenant disposé à
accueillir un public plus nombreux pour
les 20 prochaines années
vingt prochaines années que le billard
club sinois espère aussi belles que
celles qui viennent de s'écouler
voilà un joli coup fin de ce journal
prochaine édition vendredi
même un nous reviendrons sur les
commémorations du 8 mai 45
également sur le mode ds cette course à
pieds dans la boue qui se déroule à
benne jusqu'au 11 mai excellente soirée